[Musique]
c'est trudeau merci nous accordé cette
entrevue jeu très content d'être ici
alors vous avez choisi de faire ça dans
votre circonscription c'est chez moi
c'est l'endroit que je représente depuis
presque presque dix ans ici dans la
place on a chaque année une fête de
quartier la meilleure fête de quartier
pour la saint jean avec national de la
ville alors c'est une fierté pour moi
ici c'est un quartier qui est très
multiethnique un des plus multiethnique
au pays oui et aussi ici dans ce secteur
devraient beaucoup beaucoup de familles
qui sont en train c'est ça les deux
d'ailleurs à montréal et de partout ça
change beaucoup ce quartier mais comme
ces multi ethnique je voulais en
profiter pour vous parler des migrants
vie parce qu'on sait qu'on a eu un
afflux de demandeurs d'asile ya 14000
personnes qui sont arrivés au pays au
cours des derniers mois beaucoup ne
pourront pas rester est ce qu'on leur a
fait miroiter une vie meilleure à
laquelle ils n'auront pas droit
finalement on a un système d'immigration
qui s'applique à tout le monde qui
arrive que ce soit des demandeurs
irréguliers ou qui se soit le système
normal on appelait les mêmes règles
mêmes balises même pour par exemple les
haïtiens qui étaient venus ici après le
tremblement terre et plusieurs années il
y en a beaucoup qu'on a pu garder qu on
a pu donner à la citoyenneté d'autres
sont rentrés chez eux parce que on a
évalué que ce n'était pas des réfugiés
revenus et la misère fuir la misère mais
des raisons économiques ça y'a
l'immigration mais pour être réfugié il
faut qu'on se fuient la violence là la
guerre le conflit
l'incapacité d'un état de vous protéger
et malheureusement beaucoup de ces gens
là qui essaient de venir en réfugiés
vont être finalement trouvé à ne pas
être des réfugiés mais certains ont
blâmé le fameux tweet que vous avez
écrit juste après le décret migratoire
de donald turin pour vous disais à ceux
qui fuient la persécution la terreur la
guerre bienvenus au canada solution
terreur guerre ça fait des réfugiés ça
ce qui provoque je pense que de mettre
l'emphase sur le fait qu'on ait connu
ouvert aux autres c'est des valeurs
importantes à partager dont on est fier
mais faut aussi savoir que de protéger
cet aspect positif que les canadiens ont
par rapport à l'immigration
c'est cet essentiel c'est une secte
c'est une perle rare dans le monde
d'avoir une population positive envers
l'immigration et pour rassurer tout le
monde
il faut vous dire on a un système
rigoureux en matière de sécurité en
matière de processus qui s'applique à
tout le monde
donc vous ne regrettez pas vouloir
réécrire y ait pas différemment
aujourd'hui de feu donon voit toujours
accepté des réfugiés comme on est obligé
de le faire par rapport aux conventions
internationaux mais parce que les
canadiens veulent qu'on accepte des
réfugiés mais ça veut pas dire que notre
système est et n'a pas de processus et
n'a pas de règles pour beaucoup
d'haïtiens
c'est très difficile de retourner en
haïti vous le savez pas ce cas rien qui
les attend là bas y'a pas de travail
c'est extrêmement difficile et on a des
liens un peu particulier avec ce pays là
leurs escales port est ce qu'on pourrait
pas faire une exception parce que ces
gens-là ils s'intègrent assez facilement
il parle français mais ils peuvent
travailler
on a fait ça avec notre propre
communauté haïtienne
on a on a évalué ce qu'ils étaient venus
directement canada suite au terrible
tremblement de terre
et il y en a beaucoup surtout ceux qui
avaient des liens capacité à des liens
de parenté ou des capacités de trouver
des emplois qu'on a pu garder qu'on a pu
accepter mais il y en a quand même
plusieurs centaines d'autres qu'on a
qu'on est obligé de renvoyer en haïti
alors sur la fesse haut pour nos propres
réfugier ici on va devoir faire la même
chose pour ceux qui ont passé quelques
années aux états unis avant de venir ici
ce que vous voulez aller prendre un café
pour qu on se réchauffe un petit peu
tout à fait avant de le voir charles
hugo et c'est un incontournable
c'est vrai
[Musique]
bonjour et jeu
cette rue dont les migrants qui sont
arrivés cet été ou dues à la fin de
l'été ces migrants ils fuyaient le pays
de donald trump un pays maintenant
beaucoup plus fermé à l'immigration
beaucoup plus aussi ferme et au libre
échange les négociations de l'accord de
l'année là sont très ardue avec un
président qui est aussi protectionniste
est ce que vous êtes encore confiant
d'arriver à une renégociation à une
entente renégocier on sait que le
président il veut bien servir les gens
qui se sentent comme si le progrès des
dernières années on peut livrer la
croissance qu'ils aient des emplois d un
avenir assez à solide et il s'est fait
l'idée que deux en créant plus de
protectionnisme
saleh pouvoir les aider moi je suis en
train de vous montrer que peut-être dans
certains cas ça pourrait fonctionner
mais par rapport à l'alena
ça crée des emplois ce à donner de la
stabilité et aux états unis et au canada
et on devrait absolument moderniser
améliorer l'accord comme on vous l'a
fait plusieurs fois au cours des
dernières décennies mais que de déchirer
ça va causer énormément de peine à ces
familles qu lui il veut aider alors
beaucoup de conversations là dessus ça
continue mais je demeure optimiste
vous avez été très prudent très
diplomate depuis qu'il a été élu dans
vos relations avec lui
est ce que c'est encore la meilleure
approche parce qu'on voit que pour nos
grands dossiers que ce soit bon l'aller
là mais aussi le bois d'heure
l'aéronautique avec bombardier si on se
fait un peu on se fait un peu bousculé
dans tous et dans toutes ces discussions
est ce qui est pas tant d'être un peu
plus ferme il ya même dit l'autre jour
que vous aviez menti sur le déficit
commercial avec les états unis ce qui
est pas vrai exactement je pense que les
canadiens s'attendent à ce que je sois
là pour défendre les intérêts des
canadiens que je sois en train de
promouvoir nos valeurs mais en même
temps d'avoir des relations positives et
et diplomatiques avec constructive avec
avec le président ça peut être tentant
pour certains de d'insultés de se
croiser les bras mais je sais que
l'intérêt de l'économie canadienne des
canadiens c'est d'avoir des bonnes
relations avec les états unis mais une
des choses que ça nous a amenés à faire
c'est en plus d'avoir du bon moyen de
lier une communication avec avec la
maison blanche
on a utilisé les liens qui existent
depuis longtemps avec les différents
gouverneurs avec les différentes
entreprises et les chambres de commerce
avec avec les gens congrès il ya
tellement biliaire le canada et les
états unis que cette dynamique depuis un
an nous a permis nous a forcés de passer
beaucoup plus de temps à athis est plus
serré ses liens là il ya beaucoup
d'américains qui me disent écoutez on
compte sur toi juste est de nous amener
à une bonne place par rapport à la liste
d'un million d'emplois qui sont en jeu
au canada aux états unis et qui sont
liées à l'alena
tout à fait c'est pour ça que je
continue d'être constructif et sérieux
pendant quand on fait les
discussion vous pensez que c'est
important de rester à la table de
négociation quoi qu'il arrive
absolument et c'est nous on prend son
sérieux on va pas faire de deux grandes
de grands gestes vides on est là pour
travailler pour améliorer le sort de nos
travailleurs des travailleurs aux états
unis pour améliorer la situation
économique au mexique parce qu'on sait
que les échanges commerciaux
ça aide à ça surtout quand c'est bien
fait si ça on arrive à s'en souvient que
brian mulroney par exemple la dernière
minute avait appelé ronald reagan pour
faire débloquer les négociations vous
est ce que votre relation est assez
bonne avec monsieur tron pour que
justement vous puissiez intervenir
personnellement du monde et tout va
continuer on continue de travailler puis
je ne vais pas régulièrement de leur jeu
qui nous sont communs comme mais c'est
trop tôt vous avez passé le cap de la mi
mandat
ça a été une session assez difficile
peut-être la plus difficile depuis votre
élection
alors parlons des sujets qui ont causé
pas mal de controverses d'abord
commençons avec netflix
parce que vous savez que au québec en
tout cas la majorité des gens ont
l'impression que vous avez donné un
passe-droit à eau géant américain passe
droit
un privilège de ne pas percevoir la taxe
sur ses abonnements au canada alors que
tous ses concurrents sont obligés de le
faire
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est encore
la bonne décision on a fait une promesse
ou canadiens pendant la campagne
électorale en 2000 qu'est ce qu'on a les
portes d'accès n'est que netflix qu'on
n'allait pas imposer des taxes de plus
pour la classe d'actifs des seychelles
tout le monde l'appelle la tps on a dit
qu'on allait pas à taxer ses services
ethernet et on va pas les taxes et on va
pas augmenter les impôts les taxes pour
les contribuables mais une autre
promesse et les pales qu'on avait fait
aussi celle d'investir dans la culture
parce qu'on sait sous le gouvernement un
peu hésité pas des investissements
culture qu'il voulait faire et on a
investi 2 milliards en culture pour
radio-canada pour le conseil canadien
des arts alors téléfilm on a démontré
qu'on comprend à quel point les arts la
culture sont importants un niveau
identitaire et culturelle est aussi un
moteur économique important pour notre
société ont privilégié netflix par
rapport à ses concurrents on a on n'a
pas les outils actuellement pour aller
épouser ses impôts l'homme et ses taxes
mais c'est surtout vers les pays du sud
toute façon j'ai fait une promesse aux
canadiens que j'allais pas augmenter les
impôts pour la classe moyenne
donc pensez pas que quand majorité
personne quand même s'oppose à une
décision le gouvernement a une
obligation peut-être morale d'écouter
d'entendre on écoute et on entend le nom
je ne vais pas augmenter les impôts pour
les tax pour les contribuables
alors parlons de votre ministre des
finances bill morneau ça c'est une autre
controverse qui a dominé les débats ils
n'avaient pas placer ses actifs dans une
fiducie sans droit de regard
ce que vous le saviez il la demande il a
parlé au commissaire à l'éthique qui a
fait des recommandations qui l'a suivi
alors d'abord une perception est
certainement beaucoup d' attaques
personnelles qui sont en train de se
faire par l'opposition mais les gens
reconnaissent que peut-être la
commissaire aurait donné d'autres
instructions informations et d'ailleurs
dès que c'est devenu clair le ministre
des finances a changé sa façon de faire
et le suivi est allé au-delà de ce
qu'elle avait demande
à l'origine après deux ans dormait quand
c'est sorti dans cette recommandation
est sorti il l'a fait vous monsieur
trudeau vous avez placé vos avoirs dans
une fiducie un moment quelqu'un comme
monsieur mono at il pu ne pas voir qu'il
allait se placer peut-être dans une
position de conflit d'intérêts parce que
la commissaire à l'éthique entier devenu
ministre des finances elle lui à dire tu
peut fonctionner de cette façon aussi il
a suivi ses recommandations et c'est
seulement par la suite que l'adieu au
bate aurait pu aller à faire d'autres
choses et du hockey et il a fait
d'autres choses
il est suivi la lettre plutôt que
l'esprit du règlement parce que quelques
documents pour un d'un gouvernement
ouvert responsable vous vous êtes engagé
vous même ce cas ce que vous et vos
ministres évite tout conflit d'intérêts
et toute apparence de conflit d'intérêts
ça semble pas avoir été le cas pendant
seulement pour monsieur morneau il a
écouté les conseils de la commissaire à
l'éthique
hélas si on veut dire il y aurait pas dû
écouter les conseils auraient dû aller
au delà de ce qu'elle disait je pense
que quand on quand on arrive dans un
nouvel emploi on est on est censé suivre
les recommandations des experts qui ont
dit fais ceci puisse avec arrêt qui
éditera bien je vais faire je vais faire
ça je vais à l'aise avec cette année
cette décision coûteuse c'est une
décision qu'il a prise
il est en réalité déjà accepté d'aller
au delà de cette décision originale mais
en même temps nous on reste ancré dans
ce qu'on est en train de livrer pour les
gens et ils nous attaquent les attaques
personnelles comme ça sahamies quand
même là la crédibilité de la réforme
fiscale qui était quelque chose qui
était très important dans votre
gouvernement parce que ça à brouiller le
message non vous reconnaissez le message
c'est qu'on a pu baisser les impôts pour
pour les petites entreprises comme ce
qu'a fait à partir du 1er janvier
toutes les petites et moyennes
entreprises du pays vont payer moins
d'impôts soit une grande réussite pour
nous aussi c'est difficile de faire
passer le message et d'expliquer non
cette réforme fiscale je comprends mais
il ya des choses cachées aux différents
niveaux de la communication de faire des
choses difficiles c'est des fois
difficile et oui c'est difficile de
gouverner c'est difficile de faire les
bonnes choses mais je ne m'en plaindrai
pas parce qu'on est en train justement
de livrer pour les gens vous fait encore
confiance
oui c'est lui qui va présenter le
prochain budget les qui présente le
prochain budget il n'y a pas d'autres
personnes meilleur pour faire ça parce
que j'ai énormément confiance en lui
regarder ce qui est en train de livrer
pour nous pour la croissance économique
pour les gens la marijuana monsieur
trudeau je sais que c'est une de vos
promesses électorales en même temps
qu'est ce qui si urgent pourquoi c'est
si important de légaliser la marijuana
en juillet prochain
parce que ça va vite quand même à chaque
année il ya des milliards de dollars qui
se retrouvent dans les projets du crime
organisé
parce qu'ils font de la vente
maryvonne a cédé profite pour les gan
rue pour le film organisé pour des
trafiquants d'armes qui ne devrait pas
avoir alors oui ça presse de d'enlever
cet argent-là au criminel ce après souci
de mieux protéger nos jeunes les
adolescents au canada on plus haut taux
d'utilisation de maryvonne l'accès plus
facile aux marijuana à la marijuana
ici au canada que dans 29 différents
pays développés à travers le monde
c'est sûr que ça presque ont créé un
encadrement légal pour mieux protéger
nos jeunes pour nous protéger mieux
protéger nos communautés
donc on a été très clair bien avant
l'élection qu'on allait faire ça fait
deux ans qu'on travaille avec les
provinces et les municipalités et je
pense qu'on est on est sur la bonne voie
pour pouvoir livrer sur ces protections
et ses améliorations du système pour les
comédiens quand même des policiers qui
s'inquiètent pour la sécurité il ya des
provinces qui trouve quand même qu'elles
sont un peu bousculé le québec en est
une et il y a quand même une demande
pour retarder un petit peu qu'est ce que
ça changerait si on réussit ont retardé
le calbut encore des jeunes qui vont
trouver ce plus facile d'acheter de la
marionnette et de la bière et si on le
veut pas il ya encore des criminels qui
vont profiter énormément de la vente de
marijuana et ça on n'en veut pas non
plus un moment donné il faut dire à qui
on est prêt à améliorer le système on
appris on va avoir pris deux ans et demi
pour mettre en place un meilleur système
on est en train de parler constamment
avec québec avec les provinces avec les
municipalités
mais c'est un changement qu'on fait pour
protéger la communauté protéger les
jeunes et on va le faire vous-même vous
aller fumer quand ça m'est égal
non c'est pas peut-être mais je pense
pas parce que c'est pas c'est pas
quelque chose qui me revient jamais été
un grand fan de sony de et de substances
altérant quelconque mais en même temps
ce sera légal ce sera pas ce sera un
choix que les gens pourront faire mais
il ya beaucoup de gens qui choisissent
de
ne pas fumer des cigarettes non plus pas
c'est pas bon pour la santé beaucoup de
gens qui boit pas au bois peur parce que
c'est pas bon pour la santé
les gens vont faire les mêmes choix
juste parce que l'alcool est légal ça
veut pas dire que tout le monde doit
prendre recours qu'est ce que vous allez
dire à vos enfants je sais qu'ils sont
encore jeunes mais éventuellement plus
tard compte tenu des risques pour la
santé mentale sur les cerveaux des
jeunes est ce que vous allez leur
suggérer de se tenir loin absolue on va
dire très clairement je veux dire à mes
enfants et on va dire à nos enfants en
tant que société ne fut pas la marijuana
quand on est jeune c'est mauvais pour le
cerveau c'est une mauvais pour vous et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on est en
train de créer un cadre réglementaire
pour rendre ça plus difficile pour les
jeunes de 14 15 et 16 ans d'avoir
l'accès facile qu'ils ont maintenant oui
messieurs qui enfume et déjà ils vont
finir on continue pouvoir le faire
peut-être que si on cesse on s'assure
que il ya moins de pesticides qui a
moins de d'autres drogues qui sont des
fois mélangés au cannabis on va en voir
plus sur de la provenance de ce qui va
être tendu donc ça c'est plus
sécuritaire d'un côté santé publique et
aussi on va pouvoir mieux contrôler ces
endroits de vendre un pusher il va il va
jamais demandé si tu as 16 ans à 18 ans
19 ans quand il vend la drogue et en
plus il veut en vendre plus il va pas te
demande de me vendre de la cocaïne la
prochaine fois ci au contrôle avant de
la marijuana il ya énormément de
davantage dans un système comme ça je
vous entends et en même temps je pense à
beaucoup de parents qui nous écrivent
qu'ils nous parlent qu'ils nous disent
qu'ils sont vraiment inquiets parce
qu'ils ont peur que la légalisation ne
banalise en fait la consommation et qui
a justement pour l'instant il ya quand
même une barrière qui dit oui c'est
illégal alors qu'à partir du moment où
disent que c'est légal il est peut-être
beaucoup de jeunes qui peuvent se faire
on a encore énormément de
deux messages à passer par rapport à ça
mais ça va être semblable aux messages
confus donne par rapport à l'alcool au
volant par rapport à ne pas fumer à
l'assiette de l'éducation qu'on peut
faire pour décourager ça et ils savent à
être classifiés dans cette même dans ce
même deux semaines un paquet quel sera
le grand projet le grand que vous allez
proposer au canada d'ici la prochaine
élection
d'abord il ya toujours la croissance
économique mais l'autre élément dont on
n'a pas parlé c'est la réconciliation
comment on va mieux amener comme étant
les vrais partenaires à notre réussite à
les communautés autochtones
pendant trop longtemps en tant que pays
on a échoué d'inclure est de permettre à
ces communautés de ces individus-là de
s'épanouir de trouver du développement
économique mais aussi d'être fiers de
leur langue de leur culture
et c'est quelque chose que nous devons
de réparer je sais que vous êtes
beaucoup investi dans cette cause là
vous en avez fait le sujet principal
d'ailleurs de vos grands discours aux
nations unies mais quand vous regardez
en ce moment l'enquète nationale des
femmes sont des femmes autochtones
assassinées et disparues
est ce que vous êtes déçu de la tournure
des événements parce que c'est vraiment
extrêmement difficile en impression qu
on n'avance pas beaucoup
c'est difficile mais c'est toujours été
un processus difficile c'est une des
raisons pourquoi aucun gouvernement par
amanda vous lui a lancé une enquête mais
nous on sait que lance une enquête même
si c'était difficile fallait que ce soit
fait et les familles qui vont qui
présente qui racontent leur histoire
c'est extrêmement difficile et
extrêmement positif pour eux ou s'ils
arrivent à se faire entendre se faire
écouter les question de comment on va
faire un suivi qu'est-ce qu'on commet va
encadrer con comme il faut le travail
que fait la commission se fait toutes
sortes de choses dont on va continuer à
discuter mais le fait d'avoir cette
commission c'est déjà quelque chose
est prêt à leur accorder plus de temps
parce que c'est ce que les commissaires
de man on n'est pas ce qu'ils n'ont pas
fait de demande concrète encore mais on
est en train de travailler avec eux oui
on va s'assurer que cette commission là
réussissent le mieux possible ça il faut
qu'on ait la guérison pour les familles
il faut qu'on ait la justice pour les
victimes
il faut aussi surtout qu'on arrête ce
fléau qui qui malheureusement a continué
depuis trop longtemps et qui continue
des fois c'est important pour les
communautés on le comprend et pour le
reste de la population avait
l'impression que leurs ailes les autres
canadiens comprennent bien l'importance
de ce processus de réconciliation par
passion l'impression que ça change pas
grand chose au contraire ça commence à
changer beaucoup de mentalité est dans
le concret des milliers de jeunes qui
ont commencé l'année scolaire ces années
dans de nouvelles écoles il ya on a
éliminé plusieurs des avis d'ébullition
d'eau elle a encore beaucoup à ses trios
il y en a encore beaucoup mieux on est
alignée pour pouvoir les éliminer au
complet pour 2021 comme comme on avait
promis on est en train de faire ça mais
pour revenir à votre question la
réconciliation c'est pô juste entre
gouvernements et peuples d'octobre
s'explique aussi énormément les non
autochtones et sans devoir la
conscientisation qu'on a dans le public
en général
ce désir qu'il était clair pendant
l'élection 2015 ce que les gens
voulaient qu'on fasse des vraies
avancées dans le sud c'est pour moi
extrêmement encourageants et et c'est
une réflexion qui qui qui va continuer
pendant j'espère des générations
monsieur triaud on approche de la fin
alors on veut on peut sortir un petit
peu du cadre strictement canadien mais
si vous vous demandez quel est pour vous
l'événement marquant de 2010 est qu'est
ce que ce serait
la prise du pouvoir du président trump
il a démontré une une capacité de
surprendre et de déstabiliser beaucoup
d'institutions beaucoup de relations
dans le moins qu'on puisse dire stamina
thurgood et qu'il donne un peu plus de
de deux places pour le canada de prendre
à prendre un rôle le plus de leadership
que ce soit une opération de maintien de
la paix que ce soit en diplomatie
internationale maintien de la paix on a
pas on a vous avez reculé un peu sur les
casques bleus
au contraire le canada a pris un
leadership pour pour démontrer c'est
quoi l'avenir des casques des opérations
les années 10 600 soldats vous avez dit
mission importante peut-être en afrique
finalement on n'en est pas là
aujourd'hui au contraire oui on est dans
600 soldats mais la façon de faire des
opérations de la paix c'est plus ce que
c'était avant on envoyait se sont
troupes en quelque part puis allait tout
régler
on comprend maintenant que ça se règle
pas comme ça ils sont par deux cent
mille trop d'opérations de la paix à
travers le monde 600 canadian mais bien
qu'il soit excellent nos troupes vont
pas faire une grosse différence et nous
ce qu'on est en train de regarder
on va faire une différence maximale nous
ce qu'on est en train de regarder ces
commentait ce que nous tromper nos
investissements peuvent avoir un impact
pas seulement sur un pays où on irait
mais sur l'ensemble des opérations est
ce qu'ils nous ont fait réfléchir
qu'est-ce qui vous aime parce que vous
était très enthousiaste quand vous aviez
parlé de cette mission et je le suis
encore ça paraît pas je suis extrêmement
enthousiaste
qu'est ce qu'ils ont à faire réfléchir
parce que la main nous avait un peu
changé d'idée que l'onu nous a dit
écoutez on a besoin d'une
meilleure façon de livrer pour les
casques on a besoin de plus de femmes
on a besoin d' expertise pour contrer
ces dessins de l'afghanistan qui vous a
fait bifurquer mauvais la peur peut-être
que certains nos soldats soient se
fassent tuer le nom on est on est prêt à
aussi que d'envoyer nous seuls dans
différentes parties du monde c'est c'est
toujours dangereux risson prévoit lancer
pour la faire mais ce qu'on est ce
qu'ils attendent c'est qu'on leur donne
les conditions pour réussir et pour
pouvoir réussir il faut qu'ils aient
autour de la capacité d'influencer les
autres os que les 95 mille autres
troupes à des des nations unies et c'est
pour ça plus de femmes un plus de
capacités contre les enfants soldats
plus de formation et plus d'équipements
spécialisés
c'est exactement l'engagement que le
canada va faire pour créer une nouvelle
façon de faire les opérations paix qui
sont qui est plus aligné avec les
besoins d'aujourd'hui est pas les
besoins de plus de femmes alors que le
canada même c'est difficile donc ça
c'est un enjeu qui loi mais qui est
quand même difficile admet même si on en
voyait juste des femmes pour notre
mission s'amènerait pas un gros
changement la proportion de femmes or
aussi que si on peut encourager les
femmes de différents pays d'amener des
gens les armées de plus de deux pays
d'envoyer des femmes aussi que ça fait
des améliorations concrètes sur le sol
est évidemment moins de moins 2
deux problèmes de violence contre les
femmes par les troupes onusiennes
on le souhaite alors vous allez passer
vos vacances ou cette année que celle de
l'année passée ont fait beaucoup jaser
mais se trouve hors et en famille dans
le parc de la gatineau pour port pour
noël et par la suite on s'en va dans les
rocheuses faire un petit pas de deal
dans le sud cette année stable c'est
prudent merci beaucoup monsieur trudeau
je vous souhaite de très belles fêtes
merci beaucoup
[Musique]